so i just
just finished reading the great hunt
literally like um
an hour ago it's very fresh in my head
now i'm just kind of in a daze i just
feel like i need to get it off my chest
because i have a lot of
opinion i have a lot of things to say
about this book i will be doing a
spoiler-free and spoiler-filled review
so don't worry about that i thought it
was really good it took the eye of the
world in new directions for sure the
world expands a lot and that's that was
like my first big take with this the
second i got into moraine's pov i went
okay this is uh i'm not sure if i'm
ready for this i mean in the first book
moraine is like dumbledore you know it's
like you don't get dumbledore povs you
know this kind of person who's supposed
to be above everything else and is
mysterious and that's what we love about
them but now we're in their pov they're
just a regular person too just like
everyone else it's really
interesting i was a little worried you
know early on because i feel like
writers can get bogged down with povs
and i can it can get tedious i thought
that robert jordan juggled it you know
really well there's a lot that happens
in this book too just like how in the
eye of the world i was really surprised
with how much actually
happens impressive just how much ground
has traveled throughout this series
there is kind of like this warm feeling
you get thinking about you know the
original group in the eye of the world
and them going you know uh through the
blight and land and moraine being with
them and like you know they're just you
know kids and now they're kind of having
to be their own people and figure things
out on their own there's not a lot of
lovey-dovey like
sappy moments it's kind of interesting
to me because it seems like something i
would expect out of a series of this
size would really am attached to these
characters but they don't spend they're
just really unhappy like they're just
they're not having a good time and it
affects their relationships with each
other one thing i loved a lot about this
book is that is a rand's character
development he's still to me he's still
like a kid very naive in a lot of ways
so i can i can forgive a lot of his you
know stupid assumptions that sort of
thing in this book especially there's a
lot of attention paid to rand's
development as a character especially in
the middle portion of the book when he's
really having to learn to take a lead
you know literally the book starts out
with him trying to escape he just like
pages and pages of him trying to flee
and get away from his problems that
very much changes that's just fantastic
to me
naive
is like my favorite character she just
has a great dynamic with the other
characters i just love how she is a
thorn in everyone's side and she really
thrives on anger
which is interesting seeing anger used
in like this positive way you know
that's how she channels her power you
know with anger some parts of it felt
like a little bit rehashing of the eye
of the world certain
elements certain plot devices were kind
of like okay this is sort of like what
we've been through before but there's a
lot of
new stuff for sure i would put this
right alongside of the eye of the world
right now in terms of enjoyment but
let's get into spoilers because
i've i have some thoughts i loved the
the opening of this book how it's it
feels so different and fresh from what
we went through with the eye of the
world because it's just like very
political we're meeting a ton of new
characters ton of new point of views
felt very much like dune in a lot of
ways which i love dune and just these
you know what are we gonna do about this
problem what are we gonna do about rand
you know who's listening in on us and
the factions and the red red aja and the
all different sorts of stuff i love that
i love that so much there's just fun
there's some funny scenes in these books
like rand and parent and matt's their
clothes just being burned
just like reminds me of like the office
when kevin goes to the wedding and then
the hotel staff like burns his shoes
they're just like they smell terrible we
can't really apologize moraine orders
that all their clothes be taken and rand
has to deal i think that's a an
underrated element the way clothing is
used especially in iran's case it really
adds to his like character development
and what he has to go through like he's
thrust into a position he doesn't want
to be which is the dragon reborn he
doesn't want anything to do with that
mirror that he is thrust literally into
this clothing that makes him so
uncomfortable that is trying to make him
look like a lord elevate him to a status
he doesn't want to be part of so it's
just like literally he does not feel
comfortable in his own skin throughout
this whole book it affects you know his
relationships to everyone to you know
hearing to
uh inktar to matt and perrin just the
way people interact with him when uh him
and loyal and huron get trapped in the
the portal stone world when they're on
the other side rand has to you know
become a leader and he's literally he's
a changed person on the other side for
sure celine
was
[Music]
probably my least favorite part of the
book i get that it's a setup and
everything but he rand is suspicious of
everybody instantly starts trusting
celine i go okay obviously she's no good
and there's something is up it just felt
extremely obvious to the point where i
was like can we just reveal it already
can we just can rand just figure out
that she's you know messing with them i
feel like she's gonna be maybe like a
major villain in uh book three i don't
know i also had
a little bit of problems with the way um
rand and loyal stole back the horn from
feign it just felt insanely convenient
and i was watching it kind of holding my
breath as rand is like creeping over to
try to get the the dagger and get the
horn i'm like okay this is not gonna go
well this is really dumb and it just
goes perfectly until like the last
minute of course but they're basically
like out of there with it carrion
carrion carhion what whatever that that
city's name is called i liked a lot of
what happened in chara tarjan but um we
get to see tom again and one of the most
heartbreaking scenes in the book is when
tom's apprentice is killed that was just
brutal the whole sequence like the
action sequence with um the fireworks
and stuff was unnecessary and the
trollix you know dressed as puppets it
was a little goofy for me and i i wasn't
totally on board with that but
everything else i i enjoyed i liked you
know the the game and the the great game
or the game of the houses or whatever it
is with the you know the political
maneuvering they have to go to that
party and i i love that whole sequence
when they're at this
because it's kind of like a spy thing
and they got to go in there to steal
something it's a heist i love that kind
of stuff rand just being insanely
awkward has way too much attention on
him he doesn't want any attention just
like at the beginning of the book but a
totally different situation i relate to
that in some ways not the you know being
the source of a ton of attention but you
know trying to avoid
people aguin and naive
are
probably my favorite part of this book
we're seeing these characters really
grow into themselves in a big way you
know they make some major character
development naive is trying to be taught
and trying to resist things and a gwain
is like almost jealous of how natural
naive is i think my favorite chapter in
the whole book is
naive's accepted test really showed a
lot of what drives her as a character
you know when she goes into the accepted
test it's like i want to do this so that
i can take revenge on moraine
like she's just so driven this is just
how she is like she needs to take
revenge on moraine she takes things out
with her anger she uses that to motivate
her to strive
and be excellent and
protect her friends you know she's just
very loyal i love that about her she's
fun to read matt like matt just broke my
heart like at the beginning of the book
like the way he was acting towards rand
like rand was being a jerk as soon as
matt and parent find out about rand
channeling and potentially being the
dragon reborn matt's just like see ya
you realize
matt that rand is only here for you like
he rand doesn't even care about the horn
that much like he he's just here to get
that stupid dagger that you stole you
[ __ ] like that really made me for the
first time just hate matt now there is a
moment later in the book that
redeemed matt in my eyes a bit rand
takes the the inktar and the army and
varan and everybody through the portal
stone to get to toman head when he does
this and everyone sees flashes flickers
of their
future i got a little glimpse i think of
how great matt can be when he looks at
rand and he says i'm never going to
betray you
i'm sorry i won't do it and it's like oh
that's that's that's really sad that's
deep you know like he's becoming aware i
think of his own laws as a person
i don't know i feel like i need more
time because so much happens in this
book like i'm not i haven't even
discussed
like the final act of the book which was
fantastic you know we get all of these
forces coming together the white cloaks
the the sean chan and it comes together
in a really well realized
in just these well-realized moments i
loved that the fight
that rand has with balzamon was in the
clouds and shown for everybody is just
like this
moment you know it's like this is the
moment when rand becomes the dragon
reborn
to everybody you know this is like his
spider-man far from home
uh moment also the sean chan and the way
they use the i sedai and
trap them that's just like such a
perfect opposition you know to invent
that this device it's one thing to bring
everything together into a a satisfying
conclusion
but it's another to
know how to bring it to a conclusion and
like immediately ignite the thing for
the next
book
and leave you wanting more and that's
what this book did that's pretty much
what i have to say thank you for
watching like and subscribe if you
haven't already and
check out the patreon
thanks
have a good one